ça donne la parole
[Applaudissements]
à la présidente catherine de roche pour
le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président et
permettait aussi qu'au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales je
rende hommage de notre collègue léonard
ma question s'adresse à monsieur mini la
santé concerne les propos tenus la
semaine passée par le directeur de
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
martin hirsch qui s'interrogeait sur la
femme la gratuité pour les non vaccinés
qui sont admis en hospitalisation ou en
réanimation et souhaité savoir quelle
était la position du gouvernement
la parole est torride et solidarité de
la santé monsieur virant
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice catherine de roche
madame la présidente merci pour votre
question vous connaissez ma position et
c'est celle du gouvernement et vous
connaissez la position du gouvernement
et c'est la mienne plutôt dans ce sens
là d'ailleurs
nous avons eu l'occasion d'à n'est ce
pas messieurs premier ministre veut
mettre en difficulté après le mini c'est
pas le moment madame la sénatrice nous
en avons débattu déjà dans cet hémicycle
et comme médecins et comme citoyen et
comme ministre en charge de la santé et
des solidarités évidemment il n'est pas
question d'envisager la moindre seconde
de différencier la nature du
remboursement des soins des personnes
qui sont malades selon qu'elles soient
vaccinées ou non vacciner on ne fait pas
cela avec les gens qui sont atteints de
cancer selon qu'ils fument ou qui ne
fument pas fait parce avec les gens qui
ont greffé du foie selon qu'ils aient
continué à boire ou non après les
comptes malgré les conseils de leur
médecin et on soit il est traumatisé de
la route selon qu'ils aient porté à la
ceinture ou non donc notre conviction
notre combat que vous menez à nos côtés
je vous en remercie madame la présidente
parce que votre apport est précieux
c'est le combat la conviction pour
celles et ceux qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux on peut s'en féliciter c'est
tant mieux ce sont des gens qui sont
protégés il en reste encore à convaincre
et puis reste aussi des français à
convaincre deux buts recevoir leur
rappelle leur troisième dose quand ils
n'ont pas encore eu je rappelle que le
15 février les règles du pass vaccinale
vont évoluer et on ne veut certainement
pas que des millions de nos concitoyens
se retrouve en dernière minute en mesure
de en demeure de se faire vacciner parce
qu'il serait oublier l'échéance je
profitais des secondes qui me restait
pour sortir un peu du cadre de la
réponse tant la réponse à la question
mal posée est évidente madame la
présidente
si monsieur le ministre votre réponse en
effet prendre une telle décision
ouvrirait une boîte de pandore vous avez
détail et où tous les cas possibles en
effet on ne peut pas créer un crâne un
cadre éthique spéciale à la pandémie et
le président du comité consultatif
d'éthique jean françois delfraissy nous
l'a rappelé
néanmoins j'ai été surprise que le
directeur de l'ap-hp
de par sa position de directeur rentrer
dans un débat ainsi politique et
laissant croire que la surcharge des
hôpitaux est le fait des non vaccinées
dans la commission d' enquête sur
l'hôpital que je rapporte avec mes
collègues nous auditionnons depuis des
semaines nous voyons bien que la
solution n'est pas uniquement liée à la
pandémie est lié ou non vacciner donc je
pense qu'en effet ce n'est pas correct
de sa part j'ai trouvé ça un peu
saugrenue si je puis dire
oui mais mais en plus les médecins en
effet se sont élevées même s'ils ont ils
sont épuisés pour certains du travail
qui est fait en réanimation se sont
élevées contre de tels propos rappelant
leur serment d'hippocrate
néanmoins si j'avais aussi poser ma
question c'est j'ai entendu l'autre jour
le porte parole du gouvernement
expliquait qu' il y aurait il y avait
des devoirs indéniablement mais qu on
allait vers une société avec plus de
devoirs je pense que non il y a des
droits il y a des devoirs mais une
dérive qui révèrent plus de devoirs et
moins de droits n'est pas celle que nous
souhaitons et c'est à méditer dans la
période actuelle
merci beaucoup comme l'a prévu